on August 12th 1981 IBM would hold one
of the most influential product
unveilings of all time the unveiling of
the IBM PC PCS were very much already a
thing but IBM would take the industry to
a whole another level they were the ones
that kicked off the mainstream adoption
of computers in fact within just the
first year the IBM PC would sell 200,000
units and generate over $1 billion in
Revenue far exceeding even IBM's own
expectations and things only got crazier
from there by the second year IBM was
shipping 200,000 PCS every single month
seeing this I don't think you'd be
surprised to hear that brands that were
already making PCS like apple and tendy
Corb would very much fall to the
sidelines but this absolute domination
of the computer industry didn't last
forever in fact it didn't last long at
all by the late 1980s IBM would face a
slew of knockoffs from h P Dell Compact
and Lenovo and within just 10 years they
would go from being the market leader to
being a market lagard and within just
another 10 years they would go from
being a market laggard to being bought
out by the competition for the general
public this was very much the end of IBM
as they knew it but 20 years later IBM
is still massive even after cutting
their Workforce for a full decade IBM
employs nearly 300,000 people they also
pull in $60 billion worth of Revenue $7
billion worth of profit and there's
still a Fortune 100 company that's worth
$148
billion but while they've been able to
hang on to their money the same cannot
be said about their position within the
market IBM is very much a shell of their
former selves who drive almost all of
their revenue from Legacy background
connections a rather sad state for
someone who was at one point at the
Forefront of technological development
but the the more you look at it the more
it seems like this was just a Natural
Evolution that awaits all tech companies
in fact it seems that Fang is already
undergoing this transformation so here's
the IBM ification of
[Music]
fang likely one of the most telltale
signs of a company going down the IBM
path is their Workforce historically
Fang company have boasted some of the
smartest Minds in Tech with their small
Nimble workforces they were able to
handpick each and every employee in fact
at Google Larry Page and Sergey Bren
themselves interviewed every single
candidate that was actually hired up
until the company was worth tens of
billions Su was ironically one of the
first hires that weren't personally
interviewed by Larry or Sergey I'm sure
this entire Endeavor was a very time
intensive process but it also ensured
that these companies had unparalleled
levels of Talent the only problem with
the strategy though is that it doesn't
exactly scale all that well maybe you
could leverage this strategy up until
you had thousands of employees or Max 10
to 20,000 employees but after that
quality definitely takes a hit and
that's exactly what's been happening at
fang over the past 10 years as these
companies killed hundreds of thousands
of employees Google's killed from 30,000
to
190,000 meta scaled from 3,000 to 86,000
and Amazon scaled from 100,000 to 1.6
million now all of these companies still
have a bunch of superstars but they're
increasingly become the minority for a
couple of reasons the most apparent
factor is obviously the challenge of
maintaining hiring quality at these
insane skills but there's a lot more to
it for example Fang companies today are
attracting a completely different
demographic of people back in the day
these companies primarily appealed to
Tech and product enthusiasts who were
truly excited about bringing the newest
Creations to market today these
companies primarily appeal to people who
are looking for job security High income
and status and it's not like you can
blame these people either they're simply
looking out for themselves as they
should be but it's not all that great
from the company's perspective and it's
not like they can change this reality
either the fundamental problem is that
big Tech is already big Tech they
already have a bunch of established
software and services with billions of
users each so the vast majority of their
Manpower simply goes to maintaining and
refining these Services as opposed to
building new services from scratch as
such people who are interested in
building products from the ground up are
naturally drawn to smaller companies
where they can play a larger role and
the candidates that big Tech is left
with is not necessarily people who are
unqualified or untalented but people who
are largely looking out for themselves
the reason they're joining Google is not
because they can't wait to optimize
Google's TV recommendation algorithm but
rather so that they can put Google on
their resume and leverage a brand four
to 5 years down the line when they're
looking for a new job or promotion the
thousands of Articles and courses out
there about how to crack a Fang job
interview is the most obvious evidence
of this trend the biggest emphasis for a
lot of applicants nowadays is to just
play the job interview game and break in
not actually Accel at the job after they
make it this sort of mindset not only
slows down forward progress at these
companies but often leads to backward
steps which brings us into the rapid
bureaucratization of big
[Music]
Tech it's no secret that big Tech is
being bogged down by bureaucracy in fact
leaked internal documents confirm that
these companies are well aware of this
issue but knowing about the issue and
solving it are two completely different
things because bureaucracy is basically
baked into these companies DN at this
point take corporate hierarchy for
example historically these companies
have prided themselves over running a
very flat organization in fact at one
point Larry Page even fired all managers
so that there would be no layers of
management between engineers and himself
but it's a completely different story at
these companies today not only do they
have the standard management layers but
they have way more at traditional
companies you first have your daily
laborers you know software Engineers web
developers and Hardware Engineers on top
of this you have managers directors VPS
and then the SE Suite now you want to
guess how many layers of management
Google has well they've got manager one
manager 2 manager 3 senior manager staff
manager senior staff manager director
senior director vice president senior
vice president a SE suite for the sector
and finally the SE suite for the entire
company AKA if you're an entry-level
manager at Google there's at least 10
levels of management between you and
Sunder and that's just on the management
side of things all of these companies
have a whole another hierarchy for the
engineering side of things at Google
you've got interns engineer 2 engineer 3
senior engineer staff engineer senior
staff engineer principal engineer
distinguished engineer and Google fellow
with this much hierarchy for every
discipline within the company it's no
wonder why things are being bogged down
if you want to have any sort of senior
position at these companies so much of
your focus has to be on playing the game
and climbing the corporate ladder as
opposed to just doing great work and
being rewarded for it according to a
Google veteran who worked there for 13
years Google has become a slime mold
internally taking weeks and months to
even complete the simplest of tasks and
all of this has only been made worse by
Google's own Antics if you didn't know
Google has been leveraging sneaky ways
to cut total compensation I have a full
video about it if you're interested but
essentially Google has been changing up
their Stock Investing schedule to make
their job offers seem better than they
truly are Google has also started ATT
tracking employee badges to enforce
working hours they've been offering more
jobs than ever and they're cutting down
on the amenities that were once iconic
of their work culture I'm not saying
that any of these moves are particularly
bad oh no Google employees actually have
to show up at the office now and they
don't get a free massage that must be so
hard no of course not it's only natural
for companies to want to minimize on
compensation and maximize on
productivity and that's precisely what
these new policies are aiming to
accomplish but but with that being said
companies usually don't focus on
internal efficiencies until they've
nearly Tapped Out on external growth
which brings us into the question of
where does fang go from
here the IBM ification of Fang was
largely kicked off by Microsoft for
nearly a decade at this point they've
basically given up on the whole trying
to create the next big thing effort
instead they far prefer to just focus on
their boring but very lucrative
Enterprise business they just take
profits from there and bet it on
promising consumer businesses like open
AI or Activision Blizzard if these work
great if they don't whatever they still
got their Cash Cow Enterprise business
and they just needed the exposure in
case these did work and it seems that
most fan companies are following in
Microsoft's Footsteps in their own ways
Google has largely pulled back on their
moonshot ideas and is instead betting
heavily on the cloud and trying to
become a stable giant like Azure or AWS
similarly Apple has largely pulled back
on groundbreaking iPhone upgrades and is
instead focused on becoming a stable
Services giant Netflix has largely
pulled back on trying to maximize user
growth and instead maximize on Revenue
per user and as for Amazon well they
haven't been dependent on retail revenue
for a long long time at this point in
fact the only reason Amazon is even a
trillion dollar company in the first
place is because of AWS the only big
tech company that's bucking this trend
and is still trying to create the next
big thing is meta who has been betting
big with the metaverse their own
language model and most recently threads
but aside from meta it appears that big
Tech is for the first time craving for
something other than growth stability
they've already experienced phenomenal
growth over the past 20 to 30 years and
as things are starting to slow down a
lot of them are preferring to diversify
and lock in the games that they already
have instead of going for the next big
milestone as these companies go down
this path it's likely that they'll Fade
Into the background from the consumer
perspective it's not that people will
stop using their products but rather
that it just becomes a subconscious
choice for example no one is especially
hyped about AT&T or Spectrum even though
they Supply the entire country with
internet there are more just background
companies that no one really bats an eye
about and it's likely that a similar
fate lay ahead for Fang Google is just
what you use to access and navigate the
internet Facebook is just what you use
to access and navigate social media and
apple is just where you go when your
phone breaks or become slow and you need
a new one in the meantime these
companies will likely just be filled
with more and more MBA businessmen than
corporate ladder climbers who really do
nothing but push the stock price forward
their strategy of maximizing efficiency
will only take these companies so far
though and sooner or later these
companies will begin their slow and
painful demise this however is a very
slow process that takes decades so these
companies still have quite a bit of time
at the top but their 1980s IBM golden
days are very much behind them and all
that's left is to become the new Legacy
Tech Giants of the Next Generation and
that is the sad fate of big Tech who do
you think will become the new thing
comment that down below also check out
this video if you would like to learn
about how Tech is secretly nerfing
salaries big time but until then I'm
Hari and I'll see you guys on the next
one